The Joe Rogan experience.
Let me bring up Dresden before and after the war
and take a look at that.
They say the middle of the dressing was,
is how does the son,
Jesus,
speaking of 200 degrees because of the,
when the allies palmed it,
but just take a look at the,
what it looked like before and after.
Oh,
we're so lucky.
We don't have to tolerate that shit right now.
I remember who was the guy who wrote,
um,
Oh God,
where the,
where the monsters are or where the,
uh,
I,
I wrote a children's book,
it was a call where the monsters are,
I don't know.
And he was,
we was in the war and he said,
do you believe in God?
And he said,
and he just casually said,
no,
the war took care of that for me.
I never forgot it.
I was like,
fuck.
He just died in five years ago.
I had Eddie Izzard on yesterday and we were talking about wars of aggression
that most likely we've seen the end of wars of aggression.
There's trying to conquer new territory like that World War II was probably the
last one of those.
Look at that man.
That's,
so that was Dresden.
Dresden looked like the surface of the moon when they were really done with it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That lady got barbecued.
That's terrific.
Those are all bodies,
man.
She,
and that was their stress in,
there you go.
Just that,
that bill will go,
stop scrolling.
Look at that.
What the fuck man?
Yeah.
That's what war did.
That's what World War II is.
The destruction of old Europe.
Imagine what it would look like to,
to watch those bombs hit and just level everything like that.
Well,
it's carpet bombing.
So civilians that,
you know,
the,
the objective was actually to kill the Ra,
the German worker,
to really bring that country to its knees.
It was,
it was back when total devastation and the enemy was essentially a tactic.
Um,
it was a horrible,
horrible thing.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
is,
these images is so stunning.
Oh,
here.
This is how human beings rebuild,
yet they prevail.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's okay.
Um,
we were talking about yesterday was a,
that would most likely have seen the end of these wars of conquest where people
try to take over new territory.
It's territory is no longer a commodity.
Now it's services,
it's ideas,
it's technologies,
it's it land in that sense.
What do you need?
Concept was that we're moving in a better direction and that things are becoming
less and less,
at least overtly aggressive.
More people are able to see what's really going on too and more people can
communicate mean this is really the only generation ever like these last two or
three generations where you're able to easily translate anything than anyone
saying any other country.
Like how often do you go?
Like,
I'll read like could be abnormal Grumet offs,
um,
uh,
Instagram page and it's in Russian,
you know,
and I'll translate it and so I could read what he's saying.
And I do that with a lot of other fighters too.
I just hit the translate button.
Yeah.
My,
how dope is that brings you closer to that.
Yeah,
we'll do you get to know them,
you know,
and you see that they,
they're pretty fucking similar even though they're different,
you know,
they're into family,
Ferris worship and their food and their community.
They laugh.
Yeah.
I mean,
you were at air assaults with each other.
If you live there,
you'd be in that style of living too.
And it's a hard place to live.
So you gotta be a tough mother fucker.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
But there's a pretty,
there's,
there's something predictable too about how to live their certain norms and
practices.
You know,
there's,
there's a lane with Russia being run by Putin,
that seems to me to be the last big country that might invade somebody's like
Russia being run by Putin.
You could almost see him pulling a cry me a somewhere else in the world.
You could almost see him.
I think Russia and I think the history of Russia.
I have not been there.
I was there when I was very young,
but I've not been there since I and I have people who have gone there and they,
they actually really enjoy it.
And it's,
you know,
just great people,
like great people,
the Russian people who suffered maybe more than anybody in the 20th century,
but great people and industrious and everything else.
But I do think that they're run by a gangster.
Well,
but it's not just that they're run by gangster.
Yes,
but I th I think that sometimes the way I'm a populace thinks about certain
things can inform their destiny right now.
So think about this.
If you are always invaded and you had a flat topography and tanks could roll in
German tanks or whatever it is,
and you paid such a price,
the price for that.
Again,
I told you when I went there in 1985 you didn't see any old men.
They were all killed.
But aggression,
male aggression was what kept those Nazis at bay and when they were,
when they surrounded Leningrad.
Now Saint Petersburg and stuff like that.
A lot of stories that,
and I think that when you've been traumatized,
to the extent that rush has been traumatized,
certain strengths,
you know,
the ability to stand up against aggression and to be brave and powerful,
those become that.
That becomes the commodity.
That's where,
that's the guy that gets all the money,
all the women,
all the,
you know,
whatever.
And I think that's a product of their history.
So Putin is an admired man.
Putin gets,
I bet you if putting had very fair elections,
he would get elected in to power.
He's respected you trying to say doesn't have fair elections.
Yeah,
well there's a large site.
My larger point is on the record.
I'm not saying that,
I'm not saying that's her.
I don't know anything about Russian elections,
but I will say this,
I don't know why you're putting words in my mouth while those guys get door,
what the hell is going on?
Would get elected anyway,
I think still love him.
So my fever allowed open criticism of them.
Well,
there is open criticism,
believe it or not.
Sure of the guys who get shot a well know,
openly criticized.
Then they get shot.
There's actually,
there's actually,
there is a press that is critical.
Right,
right,
right.
But it's not,
you know,
they've killed journalists.
Yes.
He's not a threat to his power.
Well,
how many,
how many journalists have been murdered?
I don't know.
But enough poisons and all kinds of weird shit.
Google,
Google journalists,
critical of Putin murdered also with supporters will beat the shit out of you.
Yeah.
So,
sure.
so,
so what I'm saying is that I think Russia's,
what are you saying?
I think Russia needs to embrace a diff,
the softer strengths.
Are you a foreign policy advisor?
Yes,
I am.
This at low.
There's a philosophy I have.
This is my philosophy.
Ready?
Okay.
So my philosophy is this,
this country is a great country and our culture is an interesting culture.
Why?
Because not only are we represented of hard strengths,
the military,
the NFL,
the fucking UFC,
all that shit.
The what?
Eagles and eagles' fucking baller,
Bro.
You're right.
It's a classic there.
Canada's fucking national elements.
The beaver.
Well,
Russia as a bear.
Okay.
But so Americans,
again,
a very aggressive,
but you know what America's trade secret is?
We've also provided safe quarter two are gentler spirits.
What this violent deaths of journalists started in the Yeltsin era.
Okay,
so they just been doing that.
Yes.
Forever.
So there's just like presidents just do that in Russia.
Always have murder,
crossfire,
terrorist act.
In 2008 there was six of those dude,
a murder Olean.
There was another six.
Listen,
two of them were brought to trial.
[inaudible].
Look at me right now.
Putin is Gandhi putting this Gandhi compared to Khrushchev,
God d compared to Stalin.
Connie compared to Lennon.
Gandhi compared to any,
anybody who was in power before him.
They,
those guys used to kill wholesale.
I mean,
that's a fact.
Up to their elbows in blood.
Who was that guy that got murdered recently that was running?
It was a political opponent.
They shut that dude down when his death was not related to the journalist's
work.
The conviction rate exceeds 90% what?
I put them in jail too.
If they don't just kill him when the debt,
what does that quote though?
When the death was not related to the journalists work to convince.
So you're talking about rates of conviction.
Oh,
okay.
That was a weird quote.
Oh,
rates of conviction are very high,
you know,
of course,
to the guy with the biggest gun in that society.
They do hold all the power to though Nasbe a notch.
Those kinds of trials.
Yeah.
You're going straight to the pokey son.
Do not pass.
Go.
Good luck with your trial.
That's true.
The judge was like,
yeah,
I listen to Ya 20 years.
Fuck off.
But aggressive,
aggressive,
aggressive part of the world.
The United States like Russia,
however,
we're smarter.
No,
we're better Wheaton.
Nope.
We protect our,
we protect our funnier up.
Why are we funnier?
Because we're better.
That's not too general,
sir.
On James at the comedy store to General,
sir,
you're being too general.
This is a quiz.
Why we're better battery,
because we,
we have protections for our,
the people on the fringes are creatives.
Our weirdos are fashionistas.
All the people that make our culture interesting.
Steven jobs,
he wasn't good at crossfit.
No.
He's going to yell at employees.
Yeah.
Either was Mohandas Gandhi and Martin Luther King,
but they,
but we provide the,
at least there was Duke recourse.
At least we know that there are softer strengths.
They have to be protected.
It makes you more interesting and it makes you more creative and stronger.
You gotta be innovative.
You're innovators are Weirdos like Leonardo Da Vinci.
I apparently was gay.
What?
Ah Huh?
I said,
yeah.
Wait a minute.
Guess what?
What?
There are a lot of very smart in Russia.
If you're gay,
it's not that safe for you to have stuff of building.
Yeah.
So what you do is when you do that with people who are creative and you
marginalize a group of pill,
cause there are different in the name of purity or whatever,
didn't think you're fucked.
Like really weird public statement about homosexual.
I like the law in Russia,
like his homosexuality illegal in Russia.
Well,
a lot of times they're acquainted with pedophiles.
The LGBT community has real trouble there and it's hard to get apartments.
It's more of a subtle,
it's hard to,
it's hard to just live and make a living.
So what happens is all those creative people who could be contributing and
coming up with beautiful ideas there,
they're marginalizes perverts,
deviance.
And that's the dumbest.
Don't get to inherit the earth.
The meek.
A lot of times that the people that provide you your fucking goodies.
Russian gay propaganda law for the purpose of protecting children from
information,
advocating for a denial of traditional family values.
Whoa.
The gay propaganda law and the Anti Gay law,
the bill that was unanimously approved by the State Duma on 11th of June,
2013th holy shit man.
Say you want to protect children from exposure to,
you know,
home activity.
Yeah.
And it was signed into law by President Vladimir Putin on the 30th of June,
2013 how long is he going to be president?
So let me,
but let me ask you a better question.
So with those kinds of laws,
those kind of laws that marginalize anybody,
that's not,
that's not normal quote unquote,
that's not traditional prototypical male female.
Right.
Awesome.
When was the last time you bought,
and I'll wait.
When's the last time you bought one Russian product?
Pleased.
Besides the fact that they're essentially a one crop economy,
which is oil and I guess some other commodities.
What happens is you kill all your creativity.
What happens is you are not a strong country.
Your weaponry isn't even cut.
That's the irony of all this shit,
right?
You have that mindset and you have one idea of what strength is.
You're going to be fucking week and you're not going to be creative as a
coalition and cough.
A good rifle.
It's a very good rifle.
Make some good shit design in 1957 I believe.
Oh,
let's just say 2012 previously holding the position from 2000 2008 so he's been,
right now he's on seven years in office.
Our sir,
he's been longer that Lauren and Matt.
Yeah,
but I mean seven now.
Currently.
And then he did it eight years before.
Yeah,
but he didn't even take four years off when he took four years off.
He was like running shit from behind.
He's got to look like I'll kill you.
Like he's like will kill you.
Yes.
A black belt in judo definitely kill you.
Yeah.
Legit black belt in judo.
Like he can actually throw people around probably smart as fuck.
And in his mind,
you know,
Putin is running a country that requires a strong man.
Yeah.
It's,
it's who they respect.
So he's caught in that too.
Even if he,
if we king of the world,
let's say you're the king of the world,
how do you fix Russia?
You,
you,
you come back,
come at them with up,
you present an idea,
the idea I just presented,
which is the idea that you might want to protect the people that you consider to
be queer as deviants and Weirdos,
nerds or whatever they are.
Because those people,
a lot of times our,
your creatives,
I don't know why,
but they are,
and think they lived in too much of a wartime culture for like for too long.
I deal that they developed this hardness to them that yes,
while they're lacking in the creativity and the innovation and make it afford
that.
And I don't.
And I think that a lot of times when you've been traumatized that you're,
you're dealing still with the residue and the trauma of World War One and World
War II.
And that's very real.
And you know,
and also by the way,
communism and having nothing and,
and you know,
they have strong communities.
I mean,
my friend went to Russia and said everybody was nice to him.
Fucking,
they're good people and they're innovative people in their quick look at how
good they are at boxing.
Anything the Russians put their mind to that they,
that they hold value for.
Like strengths,
like MMA,
like,
like boxing.
Look at how good they are.
So they're,
they're incredibly industrious,
disciplined,
smart people.
I just wish,
I'm sorry.
How do you get weed over the hell no,
I bet you don't.
I bet if you have money,
you get everything you want,
right?
If you've got money,
yeah.
If you're connected to the oligarchy,
but.